The title of this, ur, video should be, c...can we have this. The title of this video should be "How not to store passwords"
um...uh, thank you, um
because, y...you really shouldn't store passwords yourself
if you can at all avoid it
if you are running any kind of web service
and you are storing passwords
it is so incredibly easy to get it wrong
ur, that basically you shouldn't try
if you can use sign-in with facebook or twitter or google
and get them to handle it for you
for crying out loud please do
if you're web programmer
sooner or later, you're gonna have to store passwords
and this is the ways not to do it
if you wanna know the ways to do it i will kinda say that at the end
but please please please look up a recent tutorial for the language you're using.
um, by the time you watch this video,
the advice will have changed
you may be watching this years in the future
look up a tutorial that has been written the last few months by someone reputable and follow that.
how do you not store passwords.
the first instinct, the naive thing :
is just store the users passwords
so let's say you have a signup box, and you have a username and password box
the naive thing is when a user signs up,
you take their password and store it in the database as it is in plain text.
that has a couple of advantages:
first of all if they forget their password, you could just email it to them.
and it means that checking it is really simple:
when they log in again, you take the username, you take that password,
and then you check what they just typed
you compare it to what it's in the database
and if it matches, you let them in
and that is the naive approach to storing passwords
and there are still professional websites, out there, run by big corporations
that still use this strategy
and you can tell that they're using this strategy
because they email your password back to you in plain text when you ask for it
um, this is a monumentally bad idea
this is an astonishingly bad idea because if someone gets into your database
through a security hole, or because they're an insider with access
and let's be honest if you're storing passwords this way
you probably have other security holes too
then, they can just read out every user, and their passwords
so you have their email address, and you have their passwords
and let's be honest, most people reuse the same password for their email address on websites
so this is a bad idea, because it's incredibly insecure
approach number 2
slightly less naive, still a bad idea
is you take that password,
and you encrypt it,
so you hide it behind something
and encryption is two way
so encryption is so you have a key
that will lock something, and then unlock it again
so the naive approach is you take the user's password
you take it into your database, encrypt it like this behind the other thing you've locked
and then, when they log in again
you take what they've got, you go here, you unlock this
you compare them, and then you let them in!
now that's a little bit more secure,
because if someone just reads out the database you've got an encryption key there
but it's got a couple of big flaws
first of all, as soon as that key is available
the password is still visible and can still be read out
and it means that an insider, or even a hacker in some cases
can just take the encryption key as well with them
and they've still got access to all the passwords
that's a pretty bad idea
the other flaw with this is that if you have lots of people using the same password
and if you've got a big site this will happen
because lots of people will use 123456 or password1
and if I've just said either of your youtube passwords, go change it
if you have that all the encryption will be the same
so, even if you don't have the encryption key,
you can still tell that all these people have the same password, so it's probably a common one
Adobe just made this mistake this month, as we record this
Adobe, the big company
behind Acrobat, which makes PDFs
behind Photoshop, behind all the big tools
millions and millions and millions of users
their password database got breached
gigabytes of passwords lost
but it's fine..
yours ? yes mine were as well
fortunately i didn't use that password anywhere else, which is what you should hopefully be doing
their passwords were encrypted
and, that was it, it was just a lock on it
and it meant that everyone who had the same password
had the same encrypted code
unfortunately they'd also stored all the password hints with them
which is wonderful
because then you can look, oh look, there's 20 people who've used the same password here
and that one says Michael Jackson is the password hint
and that one says Halloween
and that one says "type of movie" oh look it's "thriller'
OK, wonderful it's "thriller'
and that's  one of the biggest software companies in the world didn't do this properly
anyway, so , don't use encryption
naive attempt number 3:
hashing
now i talked about this in an earlier video
a hash is a summary of a load of data
so let's say you have the password the user enters
and you know that, when they enter it, you're gonna hash it.
you're gonna put it through some kind of convolutions
that ends up like that
and then, when the users enters their password again
mutate in the same way, compare, they're the same
which is great in theory,
but unfortunately you open the same problem that Adobe had
which is that if you can tell a common password, if it's in loads of people's database entries
you probably can work out what it is
worse than that, as i've said before
Google has an index of these things
if you're using a basic hashing algorithm
you can pretty much just type the code into Google and it will give you the password back
as well as just  searching for common hashes on Google
there are these things called "rainbow tables"
which trade off computation time for hard drive space
so rather than having to calculate millions and milions of hashes,
for this one password, someone has already done it for you
calculated hashes for billions of common passwords
and just put them out in a database
it's gigabytes long, but it's a lot easier to search through that
than it is to try and do a load of calculations
so if you're using something common like MD5 or SHA1 with nothing else added
the rainbow table will pretty much help you crack that in a few seconds
i have in the past used all those naive approaches myself on things i built in my youth
i've gone back and fixed them where they're still alive
and just sort of quietly buried code where they weren't
but the approach nowadays is to use something called hashing and salting
as i said the best thing is not to store passwords at all but if you have to
the advice these days is hash; salt
so a salt is a random string of characters
that is different for every single user
it's a password you know, in your database, you can store it in plain text, it doesn't matter
the user could even know it, not it would help them with anything
that means
when the user registers, they put their password in
and it goes into the same algorithm but as well as that
you generate a random string of characters for each user
completely random, a new second password if you like
that goes in the database
and that gets fed into this algorithm too
so that comes in, mutates it a bit more, comes out with something else
so if another user uses the same password
that algorithm will get a completely different salt
from them
some people might base it on the username that's generally a bad thing to do
it should just be a random string of characters
so the same password going in from a different user will mutate into something entirely different
the point of this
is that now you just have a random string for each user
you cannot possibly pull the password back from this
it wont appear in Google
because it's a massively long random string
you can't brute force it back
by looking at what common passwords are reused
all you can do
is do the old style attack
of trying every single common password one after the other
and if your salt is long enough
and your hashing algorithm is complicated enough
then that's really incredibly difficult to do
do it right, and it's lifetime of the universe difficult to do
or at least it is, until they use the password 123456